salut à tous j'espère que vous avez
passé de bonnes vacances moi pour le
coup c'était pas mal et pour cette vidéo
de rentrée justement j'avais envie de
faire un truc un peu cool un peu chill
d'autant qu'il s'agit du 10e
anniversaire de la chaîne c'est pas rien
donc j'avais envie de faire un truc un
peu sympa aussi une fois n'est pas
coutume aujourd'hui on va s'intéresser à
des chansons des chansons populaires
voire extrêmement populaires pour
certaines mais qui ont une particularité
ce sont des chansons qui ne racontent
absolument pas ce que vous pouvez
imaginer qu'elle raconte ou alors dans
le style ne laisse absolument pas
présager ce dont elle raconte en un mot
commençant ses chansons c'est pas ce que
vous croisez alors je veux pas chipoter
parce que d'abord ce n'est pas mon genre
mais c'est pas ce que vous croisez ça
fait 7 mots même si croisait n'en est
pas réellement ce qui fait que ça fait
quand même 6 mots mais dans tous les cas
ça n'en fait pas seulement un
Nissan d'ailleurs non mais c'est une
expression c'est pas vraiment une bonne
raison bon donc vous l'aurez compris on
fait cette vidéo avec Gontran de la
chaîne Gontran h une chaîne que je vous
conseille alors que son auteur est belge
c'est dire si je vous la conseille ouais
générique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon juste un truc avant d'attaquer il
s'agit pas d'un top les chansons qu'on
va vous présenter sont pas dans un ordre
particulier simplement et pour vous
montrer que c'est un phénomène qui est
plus courant qu'on pourrait le penser on
va vous montrer des chansons populaires
de différentes périodes et je pense que
vous êtes pas prêt aussi on va vous les
présenter dans l'ordre chronologique non
je viens de dire qu'il y avait pas
d'ordre particulier aussi on va vous les
présenter dans l'ordre chronologique
sauf toute si vous me permettez cette
locution quelque peu pour faire plaisir
à l'autre alsacien
c'est moi l'autre alsacien non monsieur
le centre du monde c'est astronogeek
astronoge mais quel rapport avec la vie
la première chanson dont nous allons
parler date de 1937 et a été écrite par
Charles Trenet et Paul Misraki c'est la
chanson je chante je chante
le chant de soir et le matin je chante
ce bon chemin Charles Trenet est un
chanteur blondinet né pendant la
Première Guerre mondiale révélée durant
la seconde mort au tout début de notre
siècle et dont le sourire était
proverbial il avait la bonne réputation
de donner la pêche à ses contemporains
avec des musiques ma foi prime Sautière
et des paroles plutôt youpi tralala
zimboom on en veut pour preuve c'est
méga tubes il y a de la joie le jardin
extraordinaire et j'en passe parce que
bon voilà donc on est plutôt sur un gars
pour qui mais vous me dites si un moment
donné je peux revenir sur ma chaîne moi
c'est Gontran qui m'a appelé alors je
suis venu c'est tout mais bon si tu
préfères le faire toi je t'en prie voilà
donc on est sur un gars pour qui tout le
monde il est beau tout le monde il est
gentil et il y a des canards qui font
coin coin il y a des canards qui
alors je dis pas dans la dysfographie du
gars il y a aussi des chansons qui sont
moins entraînantes comme que reste-t-il
de nos amours mais la chanson justement
est moins entraînante
le reste-t-il
de nos amours oui mais il l'a chanté en
souriant le souvenir même de ses amours
le rendait joyeux le mec fallait
vraiment je sais pas moi que les
Allemands envahissent la France par
exemple pour perdre son sourire et
encore ça lui a permis de créer des
hymnes à la gloire du régime de Vichy
donc ça va et la chanson je chante de
Charles Trenet ça date de 1937 donc ça
va pas parler à tout le monde à
l'exception de gondrant qui dansait
dessus en boîte il est vrai qu'on
embalait sévère sur cette chanson c'est
un peu notre hôtel California nous quoi
ah et vous allez en parler de telles
California oui mais spoilers [__] non
mais ça suffit là oh
donc
je chante
fais partie des plus grands succès de
Charles Trenet après traîné il a plus de
1000 chansons à son actif enfin de son
vivant puisqu'il est mort c'est triste
mais on s'en fout quand même un peu
aussi et parmi ce millier de chansons
plus de la moitié ont été des succès
certes mais tout ça pour dire que quand
cette chanson est sortie c'était une
chanson très populaire et si on fait pas
plus gaffe que ça et qu'on l'écoute
d'une oreille distraite
cette chanson elle a l'air plutôt
joyeuse il faut dire si je peux encore
faire une digression que l'air qu'on
retient constamment à Uri de Charles
Trenet dans rien à se figurer ces
fissures il y a une contrepèterie
quelque part là c'est sûr ça fait au
moins deux heures qu'on s'est pas eu ça
fait longtemps que tu es là j'ai entendu
fissure mais pas du tout ah si je suis
formé j'ai entendu fissure mais pas du
tout où ça d'abord
beaucoup de testostérone sur cette vidéo
ça serait bien qu'il y a une femme pour
équilibrer un peu bonjour Je chante et
une de ces chansons qui n'ont pas de
refrain 5 couplets racontent sur un nez
entraînant la vie idéale d'un vagabond
qui chante soir et matin qui chantent
sur les chemins qui va de faire mon
château qui chante pour du pain qui
chante pour de l'eau
or un jour la fin le tiraille et il
tombe dans le fossé les gendarmes de
l'époque vous savez de ces moustachus
bien à cheval sur les règlements le
retrouve lui passe les menottes lui
disent que son compte est bon et
l'emmène en cellules de dégrisement
a-t-on l'idée aussi d'être si heureux
non mais c'est qui ce clochard qui
sourit à la vie alors que ils doivent se
lever tous les matins pour aller au
turbain
pour peu on l'envirait et ça ce n'est
pas acceptable dès lors le volant prison
et il ne le supporte pas sa vie à lui
c'est la liberté le chant les mouches
qui ne le piquent pas les nymphes
divinités de la nuit qui couche dans son
lit fait de l'herbe des bois alors il
prend une ficelle et il se pense sans
autre forme de procès le dernier couplet
montre que son fantôme a repris sa vie
de bohème cette chanson est clairement à
pamphlet contre ceux qui pensent comme
il faut sans compassion aucune pour ceux
qui vivent en marche de la société elle
n'est absolument pas triste mais
certainement bien plus profonde et
engagée qu'elle n'en a l'air
voilà voilà
la deuxième chanson que nous allons
parler date de 1970 on va pas s'attarder
dessus de 1000 ans parce que 2000 ans
c'est long
on ne va surtout pas s'attarder sur
cette chanson
parce que tout le monde connaît le sens
de cette chanson parce que le sens de
cette chanson est à peu près aussi connu
que la chanson maintenant et cette
chanson de 1970 70 c'est l'aigle noir de
Barbara
le noir
et donc de quoi parle cette chanson
Barbara qui s'est endormie auprès d'un
lac alors qu'un aigle noir arrive donc
on sait pas trop s'il est ou pas
menaçant c'est pas vraiment et donc
l'aigle s'approche s'approche à finit
par l'emmener dans ses souvenirs
d'enfance avant de s'envoler et si on
parle de cette chanson c'est parce que
si on en parle pas ça finit direct dans
les topsaires on connaît mais c'est
aussi parce qu'on pense avoir compris le
sens de cette chanson que 27 ans après
sa sortie il s'agit effectivement d'une
histoire de saloperies de merde
d'inceste qu'elle évoque pourtant
élégamment dans l'une des chansons
préférées des Français mais dites les
gars et les gars bien entendu c'est quoi
cette manie de faire des classements de
trucs préférés des français vous savez
qu'on ne fait pas ça chez nous quoi donc
bah des classements de trucs préférés
des Français
d'après une étude BVA de 2015 les trois
chansons préférées les Français sont
Mistral gagnant de Renault ne me
quittent pas de Jacques Brel et l'aigle
noir de Barbara bon déjà ne me quitte
pas n'est pas une chanson française
espèce de
espèce de nom belge
pensez bien que vos conneries on est un
peu rien à carrer pourquoi Yanni n'a
plus de textes que moi alors qu'ils s'en
fout complètement tu veux plus de textes
oui ok moi je t'envoie du texte il y a
pas de problème
voilà ça va arriver
très bien
maître corbeau sur un arbre perché
tenait en son bec un fromage maître
Renard par l'odeur à léché vous foutez
de ma gueule voilà et si j'ai bien
compté tu as maintenant plus de texte
que Yann merci du coup je dis merci
voilà donc en 1997 dans les mémoires
posthumes de Barbara le monde découvre
que celle-ci a été abusé par son père
quand elle était enfant ce qui ne manqua
pas de susciter quelques interprétations
psychanalytiques de ces textes et
notamment selon l'écrivain est néanmoins
psychanalyse Philippe Grimberg les
paroles de l'Aigle Noir sont à
rapprocher d'un texte de Freud datant de
1910 intitulé un souvenir d'enfance de
Léonard de Vinci dans lequel il revient
sur un souvenir d'enfance
Léonard de Vinci dans ce souvenir
d'enfance Léonard de Vinci parle d'un
vautour qui s'approche de lui lui ouvre
la bouche et lui frappait l’œuvre avec
sa queue voilà donc pour Freud
évidemment il en fallait pas plus pour
en déduire que vous avez compris et donc
Grimberg fait un rapprochement similaire
avec l'aigle noir de Barbara
peut-être qu'il a raison j'en sais rien
parce qu'après tout c'est vrai que
Barbara parle effectivement des sévices
qu'elle a subi quand elle était enfant
donc pourquoi pas donc si j'ai bien
compris et tu m'arrêtes si je dis une
bêtise en réalité tu parles de cette
chanson non pas vraiment pour évoquer
l'inceste dont effectivement tout le
monde a déjà entendu parler non je parle
de cette chanson parce que justement
l'interprétation dont tout le monde a
plus ou moins déjà entendu parler n'est
pas garanti notamment une autre
interprétation tout aussi plausible
peut-être même plus encore nous vient de
Patrick Bruel en vrai c'est pas étonnant
Patrick Bruel est fasciné par la
chanteuse depuis qu'il est enfant il a
même rencontré et sorti un album dans
lequel il reprend ses chansons un album
qui s'appelle très souvent je pense à
vous tiens comment tu sais ça toi ah
mais j'en sais rien moi je dis ce que
vous m'avez envoyé bref pour Patrick
Bruel l'Aigle Noir pourrait bien être le
Troisième Reich
quelques souvenirs un peu chelou voilà
et donc la conclusion à propos de
l'Aigle noir c'est qu'on n'est pas sûr
de ce que ça signifie ce qui n'enlève
rien la beauté de la chanson
c'est tellement beau
on dirait une chanson belge ah tiens ça
je l'ai pas dans mon script non mais
c'est juste un petit pas de côté une
légère improvisation nonidiumatique t'en
fais pas là c'est tout voilà comment
j'écoutais pas oh trois fois rien
j'expliquais juste une chose c'est pour
ça j'écoutais pas ça veut dire pas de
passer à la chanson suivante parce que
là je trouve que vous dégraissez
beaucoup graissez beaucoup nous sommes
maintenant en 1977
tu penses que les gens ne comprennent
pas si je dis 77 non mais c'était juste
au cas où comme ça les gens savent oui
mais je m'inquiète tout de même un peu
me reprendre à deux reprises sur le
sujet des notes peut-être un peu de la
psychorigidité non
tu aurais pu le dire une fois
il a dit une fois moi je croyais que
c'était une légende ça ah mais c'est pas
une légende alors du tout et moi j'ai
toujours su hein
allez s'il te plaît
huit
qu'est-ce qui se passe Bruce
dans belge du coup je sais même pas par
où commencer vous me fatiguez mais alors
vous me fatiguez vous savez quoi bonjour
ah oui mais non si somme si met aussi je
préfère encore me taire en 1977 donc le
groupe de rock américain
le plus connu un morceau de bravo en
musical d'une durée de 6 minutes 30 ce
qui est pour l'époque quand même très
long et c'est quoi la Valentine c'est
Gontran qui le lit ça normalement
si ça te va bien sûr
pour supporter tous ces gens [__]
alors je continue ou bien je m'en moque
mais si tu savais à quel point pour tout
dire je m'en moque comme de ma première
moule frite ah non il est vexé
alors bon je veux bien mais alors bon
cela dit comme je suis un garçon poli un
tout grand merci à toi madame de
comptoir reviens quand tu veux par
exemple pour couper la parole aux autres
donc en 1950 27 le groupe des Eagles
sort la chanson hôtel California
parce que hôtel California réputé sur
Youtube comme étant la chanson avec
laquelle tu te fais immédiatement clame
je dis ça pour toi mais t'inquiète tu
penses bien que j'ai prévu le coup
[Musique]
Franck Franck oui
qu'on disait pas qu'on voyait que
c'était toi qui jouait ah mais ça moi
j'y peux rien c'est pas moi qui fait le
montage
c'est qui
hôtel California à l'instar de l'Aigle
noir est une chanson pour laquelle plein
d'interprétations ont été faites
certaines clairement fantaisistes et
j'en ai emballé des meufs en boîte sur
cette chanson là tu m'étonnes c'était
parfait pour conclure si je comprends
bien moi j'ai dansé en boîte sur
chaltenay tandis que Sébastien qui a au
moins 200 ans de plus que moi il a pécho
sur hôtel California
ce texte est une fumisterie
rien de plus foutez vous pas de ma
tronche s'il vous plaît sous prétexte
que c'est moi qui écrit ce texte je dois
accepter tout ce que vous dites sur moi
alors permets-moi de préciser un peu de
jalousie et paranoïa avec des amis comme
vous il n'est point besoin d'ennemis
laissez-moi vous le dire t'inquiète
après cette vidéo tu en auras quand même
deux ou trois on s'écarte un peu du
sujet là non qu'est-ce qui arrive à Yann
là c'est rien il a juste entendu le mot
écarte alors bon là il se fait son petit
film dans sa tête il nous en ont plus là
il y a des mots qu'on évite de prononcer
devant lui
ah d'accord
il sera de retour avec nous dans
quelques minutes non là où c'est plus
chiant c'est quand ça lui arrive quand
il conduit par exemple ou quand tu
donnes une conférence quoi pour le dire
simplement
pour beaucoup de gens d'une manière ou
d'une autre telle California parle de
satanisme bon déjà une info que vous
avez pas comme ça je vous la donne c'est
que hôtel California et musicalement
largement inspiré d'une chanson de Jess
rottle vous savez le flûtiste il se
prend pour un flamant rose une chanson
de jasrotal donc et qui s'appelle oui us
to know
[Musique]
toute une légende selon laquelle cette
chanson parle en réalité de l'église
satanique de Californie pourquoi pour au
moins deux raisons déjà dans les paroles
on peut entendre des just can't kill The
Beast ils ne peuvent tout simplement pas
tuer la bête
et un autre moment de la chanson that
spirit Hills 9
esprit présent depuis 1969 or l'église
satanique de Californie a été fondée en
1969 par un gars qui s’appelle Anton la
veille dans un immeuble abandonné qui
s'appelle depuis hôtel of California
voilà donc c'est pas tout à fait
étonnant si des gens voient un rapport
avec l'Église satanique surtout qu'il
semble bien que sur le verso de la
couverture de l'album couverture pour
laquelle les Eagles avaient invité plein
de monde une seule personne est à
l'étage dans l'ombre isolé des autres
et cette personne n'est autre cantonne
la veille en personne
sauf que ça c'était la version
convaincante de l'histoire et vous le
savez mes amis il ne suffit pas qu'une
histoire soit convaincante pour qu'elle
soit vérifiée ah ça y est la zététique
en goguette revient en force tu avais
pas arrêté ta chaîne toi eh attends
attends moi j'ai rien dit j'ai rien fait
je me suis juste content de dire que ça
c'était la version convaincante de
l'histoire parce que déjà l'église
satanique du Californie elle a été
fondée en 66 et pas en 69 ensuite les
seules mentions que je trouve sur
internet de hôtel of California c'est
justement sur des sites qui font le lien
entre la chanson hôtel California et le
satanisme
donc pour des sources crédibles on
passera
et enfin le gars sur la couverture
[__] mais c'est pas du tout en tonne
la veille en fait mais je peux vous dire
que pour un gars comme moi qui est
grandi avant Internet cette chanson elle
parlait de satanisme
à dire c'était bon j'en avais rien à
carrer mais c'était un fait connu et
avéré mais alors vous allez me dire de
quoi elle parle cette chanson du coup la
chanson a été composée par les Eagles
soitder et Glenn mais on doit surtout
les paroles à Glenn free si vous ne
connaissez pas bien le groupe ne vous
forcez pas vous ne retiendrez pas les
noms de ces membres qui se ressemblent
tous les noms bref si cette chanson ne
parle pas de l'Église de Satan il ne
s'agit pas pour autant d'un lieu
paradisiaque oh mon dieu non cette
chanson raconte la fuite du narrateur
qui déboule dans un lieu où il se
retrouve enfermé et donc il ne peut pas
quitter
[Musique]
et s'il est effectivement question d'une
bête qu'il est impossible d'abattre
c'est parce qu'en réalité hôtel
California est un centre de
désintoxication et la Bête dont il est
question et bien sûr l'addiction
substance qui dans le meilleur des cas
font rigoler bêtement ou écrire des
chansons magnifiques mais qui souvent
fait finir son usager de façon bien
dramatique ne vous droguez pas c'est pas
bien ou alors doucement les gars
doucement et voilà donc maintenant vous
savez cela étant si vous cherchez sur
internet de quoi parle l'hôtel
California vous allez voir que les sites
vidéos et autres Tik Tok qui parlent de
l'Église de Satan sont légion c'est
comme un bien plus vendeur qu'une bête
question de centre de désintox pas mal
les gens s'attend
Satan légion
voilà donc on va continuer d'avancer
dans le temps on va parler de notre
chanson extrêmement populaire et d'être
fortes chances que vous sachiez déjà de
quoi elle parle c'est tellement c'est un
cas d'école mais il y a certainement des
gens qui ne savent pas donc on va quand
même la faire on est maintenant en 1983
et que fait la police en 1983
cette chanson écrite par golden Matthews
Thomas summer qui a décidément bien fait
de changer son nom en Sting parce que là
c'était plus possible cette chanson donc
raconte quelque chose de
de attendez je vous la lis en français
évidemment
à chacune de tes respirations à chacun
de tes mouvements à chaque lien que tu
brises à chaque pas que tu fais je
t'observerai curieuse histoire d'amour
s'il en est j'ai longtemps hésité je
savais pas trop s'il s'agissait d'un
gars qui est décédé et qui parle à son
amour pour lui dire que de là où il est
il sera toujours derrière elle ou alors
peut-être d'un parent qui parle à son
jeune enfant pour lui dire je serai
toujours derrière toi pour t'accompagner
pour t'épauler un peu comme la chanson
de la regretter terré Moïse je serai là
sauf que non il s'agit pas de ça en fait
dans cette chanson Sting ne s'adresse
pas à un enfant mais à son amour perdu
ce qui en fait a priori une chanson
d'amour quand même comme l'indique le
refrain que je m'en vais vous traduire
une fois encore
ne vois-tu pas que tu m'appartiens comme
mon pauvre cœur souffre à chaque pas que
tu fais c'est une chanson de Stalker
voilà on va pas tourner autour du pot
pendant 1000 ans c'est une pure chanson
de Stalker alors en plein divorce avec
français Sting qui est vraiment dans le
bad se réveille en pleine nuit il est
réveillé par cet air qui lui tombe dans
la tête et cet enchaînement d'accord et
donc il va l'écrire en une heure en
pleine nuit il a dilué à plusieurs
occasions qu'au moment où il l'a écrit
te il pensait que c'était une chanson
d'amour apaisante mais c'est juste quand
il a fini de l'écrire ou peut-être
quelques temps après qu'il s'est dit
mais elle est hyper battante en fait
cette chanson et il est d'ailleurs
encore à ce jour très surpris de croiser
des fois des gens des mêmes des
anglophones natifs qui lui disent eh
mais la chanson là c'était la chanson de
notre mariage
et il dit ah c'est bien voilà on ne
s'étend pas plus sur celle-ci parce que
l'histoire est comme on l'a dit tantôt
très connu à se demander d'ailleurs
pourquoi on fait cette vidéo cela étant
nous restons en 1983 pour parler d'une
autre chanson une chanson allemande en
1982 à Berlin à Berlin Ouest ah oui ok
il va falloir un tout petit peu de
contexte en 1989 comme vous l'avez sans
doute appris à l'école et tomber un truc
qui s'appelait le mur de Berlin parce
qu'il y avait un mur à Berlin qui
coupait Berlin en deux
depuis un peu après la deuxième guerre
mondiale parce qu'à l'époque il y avait
pas une seule Allemagne il y avait deux
Allemagne il y avait à l'ouest la RFA la
République fédérale d'Allemagne et à
l'est la RDA la République démocratique
allemande au sein du bloc soviétique
guerre froide tout ça tout ça et donc
Berlin était globalement coupé en deux
Berlin Ouest et Berlin Est avec comme
séparation un mur au milieu de ce mur le
fameux Checkpoint Charlie qui était le
point de passage de l'Est à l'Ouest et
du Nord au Sud l'Allemagne était donc
scindé en deux par une espèce de no
man's land encadrée par des grilles et
entre ces grilles il y avait des champs
de mine ça je le rappelle très bien
quand j'étais gamin le long le long de
cette grille et les panneaux avec marqué
Arto minnen et au loin on voyait des
miradors je me rappelle très bien bref
on est en 1982 à Berlin Ouest il y a un
concert des Stones auxquels assistent
Carlo cargès guitariste de son état et à
la fin de ce concert il y a lâcher le
ballon qui dans la nuit
ressemble à signer prendre à des ovnis
et j'en ai déjà parlé en vidéo au mois
de cette histoire Carlos se dit que si
ces ballons franchissent la frontière et
rêvent dans le blog de l'Est et ben les
gardes d'estalement ils pourraient très
bien riposter militairement contre ces
ovnis ce que du côté de l'ouest on
pourrait prendre pour une attaque
militaire contre le bloc de l'Ouest et
ainsi déclencher la troisième guerre
mondiale évidemment nucléaire vraiment
j'en ai déjà parlé en vidéo moi de cette
chanson que le gros danger de la guerre
froide
c'était que ça reposait quasi
exclusivement sur la dissuasion
nucléaire et c'est ainsi qui est né
cette chanson qui quand on l'écoute sans
la comprendre à l'air tout à fait
joyeuse
non
littéralement
99 ballons de baudruche attention parce
que cette chanson là c'est le climaturé
j'ai le droit donc je m'en bats les
couilles
[Musique]
99 ballons en route vers ton horizon on
les prenait pour des ovnis venant de
l'espace c'est pour cela qu'un général a
envoyé une escadrille d'avion à leur
trousse c'était pour donner l'alerte
qu'il a fait ça et pourtant il n'y avait
là à l'horizon que 99 ballons 99 pilotes
d'avion à réaction chacun d'entre eux
était un grand guerrier il se prenait
pour le Capitaine Kirk
cela a donné un grand feu d'artifice les
voisins n'ont rien capté et se sentaient
tout de suite provoqué et pourtant on a
tiré à l'horizon sur 99 ballons 99
ministres de la guerre l'allumette et le
jerrican des sens se prenait pour des
gens malins ils feraient un gros butin
il criait la guerre et voulait le
pouvoir mais qui aurait pu penser cela
qu'on en arrive là un jour à cause de 99
ballons 99 années de guerre n'avaient
même pas laissé de place pour les
vainqueurs des ministres de la guerre il
y en avait plus aucun et aussi plus
d'avion à réaction aujourd'hui je fais
mes rondes je vois que le monde est en
ruine j'ai trouvé un ballon je pense à
toi et je le laisse s'envoler
alors ça paraît un peu con d'imaginer
comme ça une guerre mondiale qui
pourrait être déclenchée par des ballons
mais j'en connais un qui pourrait vous
raconter des trucs sur le sujet oui
alors j'ai effectivement commis quelques
vidéos sur les fois où on est passé à ça
de la troisième guerre mondiale ce qu'on
appelle les clauses calls et parfois
effectivement pour des conneries plus ou
moins aussi bêtes qu'un lâché de ballon
je vous mets des liens dans la
description et puis vous savez quoi
bonjour
non mais là vraiment vous savez pas en
fait je sais pas c'est que cette chanson
ça me fait penser à une autre chanson
sur le thème un peu militaire comme ça
par contre c'est une chanson qui date
d'un peu à vendre donc on va faire un
petit bon dans le passé nous sommes en
1980 et un groupe de pop britannique au
nom parfaitement un prononçable
orchestre in the dark qui signifie
littéralement manœuvre orchestrale dans
l'obscurité et puis tant c'est vraiment
un nom à la con bref ce groupe sort une
chanson que tout le monde connaît au
moins pour son refrain instrumental donc
voici un court extrait
[Musique]
et de quoi parle cette chanson le
chanteur s'adresse à un pilote d'avion
et lui demande comment ça va comment il
se sent est-ce que sa mère est fière de
lui ce genre de chose sauf que le pilote
et le pilote de l'Enola Gay un
bombardier B29 de l'armée américaine qui
le 6 août 1945 l'Arga la bombe atomique
little boy sur Hiroshima
[Musique]
voilà quoi bah oui qu'est-ce que vous
voulez on a bien du malheur vous savez
voilà donc la chanson de United je me
faisais penser à ça donc on en a parlé
mais bon c'était juste une parenthèse on
va pouvoir reprendre le film normal de
notre vidéo faire un vrai bon dans le
temps cette fois-ci pour aller atterrir
en 1994 sur un sujet certes beaucoup
plus léger vraiment ah j'avoue et je ne
sais pas si c'est intéressant que tu le
saches mais je ne déteste pas les sujets
plus légers alors notons qu'on n'est pas
non plus sur un sujet vraiment léger
c'est juste plus léger que l'apocalypse
quoi
je peux être franc avec toi je savais
pas qu'il y avait des paroles c'est
normal on est dans les années 90 c'est
pas franchement les décennies des
chansons à texte et donc c'est une
chanson des années 90 alors oui non en
vrai cette chanson c'est un genre de
remake en fait c'est une chanson qu'on
sait pas trop bien datée d'ailleurs
parce que on sait quelle date d'avant la
guerre de Sécession donc à la
vraisemblablement été écrite entre 1800
et 1860 ah oui tout de même
si ça se trouve Sébastien bien connu
l'auteur j'ai fini oui cette chanson sur
laquelle vous avez absolument tous dansé
que ce soit sincèrement ou de façon
ironique cette chanson parle de MST
voilà d'une maladie sexuellement
transmissible et qui aurait comme
symptômes de donner le regard un peu
cotoneux ah ben je laisse un homme c'est
bon maladie refiler le chanteur par
cotton eye Joe littéralement Joe aux
yeux de coton et une fois qu'on a ça en
tête
les paroles sont d'une clarté sans le
Cotton eye Joe je serais marié depuis
longtemps
d'où es-tu venu où tu en es-tu allé d'où
es-tu venu quand on aille Joe
[Musique]
sinon il y a d'autres trucs que tu aimes
dans la vie à part nous pourrez notre
enfance à Macarena raconte l'histoire
d'une meuf qui se décrit comme bonne et
qui veut se taper tous les mecs bon de
son entourage parce que son petit ami
n'est pas bon et elle finit par se
barrer et se taper les deux meilleures
amies de son petit ami parce que c'est
deux meilleurs amis sont bons
je te déteste oh là mon ami ce n'est pas
très gentil que de dire ça déjà à la fin
de l'été quand j'étais entendu parler de
Charleroi ce n'était pas forcément
aimable alors s'il te plaît il a dit
quoi sur charleroi
pas grand chose à dire sur charleroi si
on veut pas être désagréable il me
semble que c'était pas le sujet en effet
attention à ne pas présumer des
intentions des autres le fameux procès
d'intention qui est toujours fondé sur
nos a priori ces espèces de petits biais
qu'on a
est amis n'est-ce pas
mon meilleur ami préféré super et donc
je t'ai déjà dit ta gueule non je non
bon et bien ta gueule Gontran mais
calme-toi je sais pas boire un verre
d'eau quoi
bon on approche de la fin de toute façon
on est maintenant en 1998 en France chez
M6 c'est de la production locale tout va
bien se passer bah tant qu'on ne va pas
dans des sujets clivants
pourquoi tu ne dis plus rien
Bruce est-ce que vous vous rappelez
de Sandy Valentino oui oui vraiment si
la réponse est oui félicitations vous
êtes vieux
[Musique]
tu vois je ne me souviens plus du tout
de cette chanson
c'est bon d'être jeune oui mais gare à
l'illusion logique car si Bruce dit que
ceux qui connaissent la chanson son
vieux ça ne veut pas pour autant dire
que ceux qui ne connaissent pas la
chanson sont jeunes je suis jeune et oui
d'autant que c'est complètement faux
puisque en l'occurrence ben ceux qui
connaissent la chanson peuvent aussi
être jeunes la probabilité est plus
faible mais elle existe Bruce s'enchaîne
s'il te plaît je sens venir le rasoir
d'okham là et je suis pas d'attaque en
1998 apparaît donc sur nos écrans sur M6
une chanteuse nommée Sandy Valentino ah
je connais bien elle ah bon bah oui
parce que bon elle fait pas de chanter
aussi fait le Andy
[Musique]
Valentino moi je parle de Sandy
Valentino ah oui ah non d'accord oui non
en fait
donc la chanson de Sandy Valentino
s'appelle pourquoi et c'est une chanson
qui est ultra entraînante hyper joyeuse
tout le monde danse le clip se passe sur
un panier d'immeuble où il y a tout le
monde qui danse alors il y a le livreur
de pizza il y a des danseurs dans
breakdance il y a des haricrishna je me
demande même s'il y a pas des plongeurs
à un moment donné enfin c'est n'importe
quoi c'est le carnaval si bien qu'on ne
fait généralement pas vraiment attention
aux paroles pourquoi pourquoi tout ça
n'arrive qu'à moi et pourquoi est-il
tombé sur moi mais cache donc fait
qu'a-je donc fait pour mériter ça ça
c'est le refrain et alors en matière de
couplet le premier couplet je vous le
dis voilà
comme tous les matins dans la salle de
bain et de bonne humeur j'essaye
d'oublier qui est au dîner j'étais tout
en pleurs il me fait ranger tout ce
qu'il a dérangé en moins d'un quart
d'heure je l'entends crier je lui amène
son café pour lui quel bonheur et le
pont musical vous savez c'est la partie
qui entre couplé de refrain
ça fait des mois que ça dure il mourra à
l'usure il me fait peur mais fait battre
mon cœur
il me tape sur les nerfs mais voilà le
dilemme moi je l'aime maintenant faut
vous imaginez être en train de danser
là-dessus
moi j'aime bien c'est sympa bonne
ambiance
si je comprends bien et tu m'arrêtes si
je dis une bêtise n'est-ce pas cette
chanson explique que la chanteuse vit
sous l'emprise de son compagnon qui
abuse d'elle exactement ah oui quand
même c'est vrai que c'est pas du tout
clivant
et ça se termine bien je veux dire il y
a une face cette histoire alors s'il y
en a une ben en tout cas c'est pas dans
cette chanson parce que cette chanson
elle se termine en aide libre c'est à
dire avec le refrain qui se répète en
boucle cette triste tout de même je peux
dire un truc juste deux secondes
alors personnellement je préfère sa
chanson de la peau ah bon
de la peau
en nous le sens même des mots bon c'est
pas un chef-d'oeuvre en particulier mais
ça c'est cool bien je préfère bon on a
fait le tour là non fait le tour c'est
pas vraiment possible de faire le tour
il y a beaucoup trop de chansons je
regarde par exemple on a pas parlé de
plus que tout au monde de Pascal Obispo
qui parle de fellation
j'écoute et je reviens et si on part
dans d'autres langues alors là pardon
mais on peut y aller c'est-à-dire que si
on comprend pas un Brogue de ce qui se
raconte
personne ne sait de quoi parle Gangnam
style par exemple et de quoi ça parle je
ne sais pas pour le coup Gangnam style
ça parle de ce que vous pouvez imaginer
que ça parle une fille chaude comme en
plein jour une fille qui s'est appréciée
la liberté d'une tasse de café une fille
dont le cœur se réchauffe quand la nuit
arrive une fille avec ce genre de
déformation je suis un gars un gars
aussi chaud que toi durant la journée un
gars qui peut boire son café cul sec
avant même qu'il refroidisse un gars
dans le cœur déborde quand la nuit
arrive ce genre de gars
tiens pH despacito ça parle de quoi je
veux voir tes cheveux danser je veux
être à ton rythme apprends à ma bouche
tes endroits préférés permets-moi de
survoler tes zones de danger jusqu'à ce
que tu cries et que tu oublies ton nom
pas mal cette chanson en fait juste
excuse-moi pourquoi est-ce que à chaque
fois que vous devez une réplique viscère
à dire ça tombe automatiquement sur moi
titre
toi ta réponse sinon Bruce la chanson
qui est à l'origine de l'idée de cette
vidéo on peut en parler maintenant on
peut le faire les gens on est maintenant
en 1973 le chanteur italien Adriano
Celentano sort une chanson rock qui
tourne sur un seul accord c'est une
chanson qui est ultraviscérale et cette
chanson s'appelle
prison
dis tu sais bien le prononcer toi ce
titre c'est un métier
[Musique]
bon alors dans le premier texte que tu
m'as donné à lire Bruce avant que je ne
le réécrive pour qu'il collent mieux à
ma faconde et qu'il soit plus parfait tu
me disais de dire j'aime beaucoup ce
clip avec les miroirs
je trouve néanmoins et avec tout le
respect que je te dois que cette phrase
est loin d'être à la mesure du culte que
je vous à l'ensemble du phénomène
gidolâtre la chanson et je suis hyper
fan du clip en effet car je le trouve
hyper avant-gardiste la chorégraphie est
géniale et l'ambiance est complètement
folle voilà c'est dit avec les miroirs
on a l'impression qu'ils sont 3000 alors
qu'en fait les danseurs c'est 16 pays
quoi et la jeune femme qui chante avec
lui la jeune femme qui chante avec lui
c'est sa femme à Celentano par exemple
et c'est vrai qu'elle envoie du pâté
dans cette chanson tu dis ça comme ça
TOI bah ouais
[Musique]
et alors si on parle de cette chanson
c'est que le sujet va nous paraître hors
de propos
Bruce on est sur ta chaîne je te laisse
la primauté de la danse Celentano très
inspiré par la musique américaine décide
d'écrire une chanson sur le thème de la
difficulté à communiquer notamment à
communiquer son amour de son prochain il
décide d'écrire cette chanson en anglais
en anglais phonétique précisément une
langue 100% inventée mais qui sonne
comme de l'anglais dire à l'exception
des mots alright
tous les mots sont inventés mais
attention les paroles sont pas
improvisées elles sont écrites elles
sont inventées mais elles sont écrites
c'est-à-dire que d'une prestation à
l'autre challen Tano il chante et même
parole c'est juste que ça veut rien dire
et quand la chanson est sortie elle a
marché en Italie à marcher dans toute
l'Europe cette chanson d'ailleurs
Celentano avait déjà fait un peu la même
chose dans le film La Dolce Vita de
Fellini en 1960 quand il reprenait le
titre de Little Richard ready Teddy mais
dans une sorte de yaourt
incompréhensible ce qui est appeléonasme
et je m'en excuse pareil dans le même
esprit vous connaissez tous la chanson
Ameno
[Musique]
là pareil voilà si ça sonne latin mais
ça veut rien dire
c'est en quelque sorte la chanson du roi
lot ok c'est bien c'est super tout ça
voilà
bon sinon on a fini j'ai faim moi
j'aimerais bien les manger on a fini
donc déjà avant toute chose un immense
merci avec votre en H de la chaîne
Gontran h que je vous invite à découvrir
si vous ne connaissez pas sa chaîne le
lien dans la description vous savez
alors il vous faudra un temps
d'adaptation pour vous habituer à son
accent chelou et au fait qu'il sait pas
dire 8 correctement mais sinon une fois
que ce sera passé vous verrez sa chaîne
et truculente j'avais envie de dire
truculente merci également à Arnaud de
la chaîne astronogeek que normalement
vous connaissez déjà ainsi que Yann solo
de la chaîne 12 parsec pH du point
Genius et Monsieur Sam de la chaîne
monsieur Sam et de la chaîne monsieur
Sam oui les différences entre les deux
chaînes dans la ponctuation c'est le mec
est chiant mais ces chaînes ne le sont
pas donc vous pouvez y aller sans
problème merci également à Valentine de
la chaîne sciences de comptoir pareil je
pense que vous connaissez déjà également
Sébastien de la chaîne vous avez le
droit une excellente chaîne qui parle de
droit enfin et pas des moindres Franck
de la chaîne matador une chaîne musicale
s'il en est ouais non alors pas du tout
en fait c'est une chaîne qui est
consacrée au maths à l'histoire des
sciences et à l'esprit critique ah bon
mais moi je croyais parce que c'était un
musicien oui mais non bon bref tous les
liens sont dans la description pour le
reste vous savez que la vidéo il faut la
partager vous pouvez mettre des pouces
des commentaires le tipee maintenant
juste une seconde là quoi à chaque fois
on bazarde le tipi avec les commentaires
et les likes je trouve qu'on pourrait
faire un petit effort pour les tipeurs
quand même un immense merci à tous les
tipeurs toute l'équipeuses passer
présent et peut-être à venir là c'est
vrai que comme je fais moins de vidéos
que je suis un connard j'ai souvent
tendance à pas verbaliser le truc mais
j'apprécie énormément vos types bien sûr
il participe à faire vivre cette chaîne
donc encore une fois je vous le dis
merci je sais pas mal quand même de dire
merci de temps en temps oui
on se retrouve très bientôt pour la
suite d'ici là portez-vous bien
[Musique]
et à bientôt